da ist ein widerhall bern luca euer
lieblingskino für sich jeder hat sich
mal wieder einen blickfang gremmel
stream ich hab mich im kasten gestellt
und damit machen wir heute ein
experiment
falls ihr euch fragt warum hier oben
wäre video eingeblendet steht das hat
nichts mit ihnen zu tun sondern mit der
ideenexpo 2009 10 aber dazu kommen wir
gleich denn zunächst einmal an was wir
hier alles in unserem team haben zum
aller ersten mal als ich habe ja schon
zwei videos hochgeladen hat nie so gut
geklappt auf jeden fall häufig zum
ersten mal tatsächlich so ein ding und
das ganze rein stellen sollten das jetzt
ist jede auf mein handy gefallen
funktioniert aber noch nicht auf jeden
fall haben wir zum ersten mal so eine
richtige grundlage wo das ganze zeug
hier einstellen können was das hier das
waren untersetzer also gut ich habe
keinen plan wo diese unterzahl hierhin
kommen müssen dann können die teile
anzünden
okay das interesse an diesem
chemiebaukasten ist das wäre tatsächlich
so richtig karten drin haben und dann
von mir mit meinem schneiden
lässt du dir du brauchst einen grossen
mass welche habe ich nicht verbittert
und ein heute ich habe parade wollen
also werden wir doch richtigen schleim
machen sondern irgendwas mit dem also
das sind die stoffe die damit gegeben
wurden das kokain war ja ich mache das
ganze jetzt auf meine art und 20 mehr
als erstes hier liegt eine tablette und
packte die ich hier in mein glas einmal
sechser schon vorbereitet habe
da ist jetzt eine tablette vergessen wir
füllen jetzt einfach mal ein bisschen
wasser hier auf die tabelle nur wenige
minuten später ok wo also wirklich zum
aller ersten mal hat hier irgendwas
geklappt in der chemie video von mir
das heißt wir schauen jetzt mal wenn ich
dort ein blatt papier reinstecken ob es
dann auch die brach das papier die ferne
warum hole ich meine leser wenn hier
auch solche teilweise und stellt das
eine mal hier rein und das andere sein
und jetzt bevor wir weiter machen sage
ich euch kurz nach oben werde video
steht denn das heutige video ist in
kooperation mit der ideen expo 2009 10
entstanden das ist eine messe die ist in
hannover vom 15 bis zum 23 juni also
tatsächlich jetzt bald schon das ist
allerdings noch gar keine richtige
klassische messe sondern hier hat und
jugendevents im naturwissenschaften und
technik also genau die richtige für mich
da gibt es halt live experimente bei
denen man noch teilweise mitmachen kann
es gefühlen chance es gibt workshops
also vergleich mit den messen auf denen
ich bisher war eigentlich schon ziemlich
neues sap com nachgelesen und es gibt
auch der komplette messe über 670
mitmach exponate über 730 workshops ich
persönlich werde am 20 juni oh mein gott
ich werde auf jeden fall am 20 06 uhr
auf der messe sein da könnt ihr euch
auch treffen also ich werde ein meet and
greet veranstaltung der eintritt ist
frei
also ihr müsst nicht bezahlen können
einfach nach hannover fahren zu messen
hin
die experimente machen zuschauen wie
andere leute experimente machen und mich
treffen haben 20 06 alle weiteren infos
dazu findet in der infobox auf der
homepage tiefer unten verlinkt und jetzt
machen wir weiter mit meinen komischen
experimenten ich mich jetzt ein
richtiges dinge aufbauen wie ich dort
schon hartplastik also den chemie tasten
sind auf jeden fall ordentlich der sache
mit dabei er mich jetzt hier und mit
luft
dieses pulver hier heißt heiko los lang
pausieren gefallen die schüsse das
einfach mal komplett in meinen
das riecht wie verbrannte haferflocken
ich habe keine ahnung ob das irgendwann
findet er kann zu hause eure
haferflocken kann das über sollen als
nächstes haben wir jetzt noch einen
glowing mittags lauda als auch eine
kleine bruder der mit dem der schleim
angeblich in der nacht leuchten kann an
dem pakt jetzt nicht in so ein fettes
glas von mir wird schon daher ordentlich
was drin ist sondern in das kleine hier
das riecht doch immer nach diesen
schritt haferflocken leute die könnte
sogar ich will da kann man noch so ein
bisschen blaues wasser die rein
das sieht ja mega grady aus ist das
ganze jetzt einfach mal mit meinen
händen so ein bisschen durchkneten
scheiße dachten das glaubt man fast
keine ahnung ob wir das machen sollen
sinken darf aber es fühlt sich auf jeden
fall schon mal so ein bisschen schleimig
an
ich kenne ich jetzt einfach mal so ein
bisschen rum film ärgert es sieht so aus
als hätte ich mir die hände gekostet
also auf dem zettel steht dass man auf
meist stärker braucht man braucht man
braucht man und hören die vor
also es ja soll ich denn jetzt hoch
kommt das war echt lustig ich habe meine
hände gewaschen und haben wir total
triple ist und das hat sich jetzt so
angefühlt als würde jeden moment wächst
aber gut kommen wir nun auch schon zum
letzten stoff der uns hier beigefügt
wird uns was hand shines like wow da wir
wissen jetzt dass die goldene mitte
wahrscheinlich so der richtige weg ist
eher dahin dass wir durch die schlei
machen können also nicht nur ganz wenig
was aber auch nicht ganz viel wasser
deswegen will ich jetzt ist es gut
einfach mal in das hier und ein
halbvolles glas ich es stinkt schon
wieder so abnormal schweiz passiert
absolut gar nix vier der dax kann man
mal so lahti war schneider haus
entstehen nicht nur das glas treffen
kann ich glaube dass sie es
schleiden ich glaube ich habe wirklich
zum aller ersten mal in einem chemie mit
luca video etwas hingekriegt und zwar
habe ich nehme ich die passende menge
gefunden umstellen na ja das schreiben
jetzt zumindest besser als nichts aber
es ist meine seele erklingt dann meine
hand nur er ist halt nicht so
ja ich könnte jetzt ein schönes
kunstwerk machen und da das ist meine
hand mit diesem wundervollen kunstwerk
hier ja genau dafür ist es gemacht luca
berg dieses lockermacht schwachsinn mit
einem chemie bau passende video gefallen
hat das gerne einen damen wo unter
diesem video hielt er abonniert bei
nacht und ich hoffe dass wir uns am 20
06 in hannover sehen die ideen expo
findet jetzt vom 15
bis zum 23 6 statt und gibt es auch
unzählige live konzerte auf den riesigen
bühnen hat deswegen mega mega meist mehr
so ein richtiges event als das ist eine
klassische messe ist würde ich sagen
also ich würde mich freuen
falls ihr vielleicht sogar 21 06 bekommt
er dann sehen wir uns dort eventuell
schaut man die video beschreiben dann
würdet ihr ihn zu der webseite
eingebettet in einen infos wie und wo
ihr mich treffen könnte dann findet ihr
auch den youtube kanal von der ideenexpo
wie jetzt kommt das abo